[Music]
this is u.s congressman louie gohmert
unlike many of his colleagues he often
refused to wear a mask in congress
and then he tested positive for kovit
19.
but in an interview he suggested that he
got kovid 19
because of the times he did wear a mask
i might have
put some of the virus onto the mask and
breathed it in
gohmert's distrust of mass is actually
shared by a ton of americans
a poll in july asked americans how often
they wear a mask
among democrats almost everyone said
they wore a mask in public
but significantly fewer republicans said
so
yet the messaging from public health
officials today is clear
wearing a mask helps stop the spread of
coven 19. so
where did this communication break down
how was something as simple as wearing a
mask
allowed to become political
[Music]
in october of 2001 the us bungled a
different public health crisis
someone sent envelopes of deadly anthrax
to media organizations and government
offices
first the secretary of health and human
services went on tv and speculated about
how the first victim might have gotten
it
we do know that he drank water out of a
stream
just because he was an outdoorsman and
there's a possibility
that there's all kinds of possibilities
we don't know we don't know yet as the
crisis continued
different officials gave different
conflicting information
no one was really in charge of
communicating to the public
and it led the u.s centers for disease
control to make this
the crisis and emergency risk
communication guide or
circ it's a guide to how to communicate
during a public health crisis
the cert guidelines are really a
reflection of the lessons that were
learned from failures
glenn nowak used to be in charge of
communications for the cdc
he's used the cirque and even wrote some
of it and he says one of the biggest
lessons from the anthrax attack is what
the cirque now calls
the most important role in a crisis and
the key to preventing mass confusion
having a single person as the
spokesperson it really helps to have
one primary voice one primary face
the circ says the spokesperson should be
someone who is familiar with the subject
matter and can talk about it clearly and
confidently a lot of communications
between a public health crisis
is about setting guiding and managing
people's expectations
it's important early on to not just talk
about what you know
but what you don't know essentially the
spokesperson needs to be seen as
trustworthy and credible
which is one reason you don't want your
spokesperson to be a politician
because it's really hard for any
politician to be seen as credible
by everyone they often only resonate
with those who support them
and they don't resonate with those who
did not vote for them
that doesn't mean political leaders
can't be involved in public health
communication
they just can't take the lead on the
science a good example of a government
following these principles during coven
19 was in new zealand
where the prime minister was at many of
the daily briefings but wasn't leading
it as as our usual practice i'll begin
by handing over to dr bloomberg what's
important is that everybody is on
the same page with respect to the
overall messaging but in the u.s
there hasn't been a clear spokesperson
or a clear message
press conferences were led by president
trump and would feature politicians as
well as public health experts
and they often contradicted each other
we do
expect more cases when you have 15
people
and the 15 within a couple of days is
going to be down to close to zero
especially when it came to guiding those
expectations
we will have coronavirus in the fall it
may not
come back at all developing very rapidly
a vaccine
that could be a year to a year and a
half these conflicts asked many
americans to pick a side
who do you believe the president or
public health officials
a medical experts dr anthony fauci
seems to favor what the democrats want
dr fauci who appears to believe he's in
charge of the country
it's important that we listen to our
elected leaders not the medical
bureaucracy
that breakdown between public health
officials and politicians can get
especially dangerous if the information
starts to change which it almost always
does during a crisis
you need to remind people very
frequently
that you're going to be making changes
based on the growing body of knowledge
and that as a result it's going to look
like you're being inconsistent
but more importantly you're learning and
you're learning what works best
early on the cdc advised people not to
wear mass
but as they learned more about the new
virus they changed the guidelines
what has changed in our recommendation
we now know from recent studies that a
significant portion
of individuals with coronavirus lack
symptoms cdc is
always always looking at the data we've
told you that from the beginning dr
burke says at
every single press conference we're
looking at the data we're evolving our
recommendations
but this shift wasn't supported by trump
personally the masks it's going to be
really a voluntary thing you can do it
you don't have to do it i'm choosing not
to do it
soon mass became the symbol of the war
between trump and the medical experts
i think it's a political hoax no i don't
wear a mask
shame on you for voting for a mass and i
say
trump 2020. by june more republicans
trusted trump than the cdc for facts
about the coronavirus
it was exactly the scenario the
communication guidelines had been
written to avoid
what's frustrating is knowing that a lot
of the or many of the challenges
are self-inflicted wounds or they're
things that could have been avoided
based on past experience in 2001
the u.s got lucky the anthrax attacks
eventually stopped
the problem went away in 2020 the u.s
made the same mistakes
but we haven't been so lucky
you